we are joined now by former national
security adviser in the trump
administration there he is h.r mcmaster
the retired lieutenant general is a
senior fellow at the hoover institution
good morning to you general we're really
glad to have your expertise on this day
of all days where the situation appears
to be getting more and more dire in
ukraine as you're watching this playoff
play out as a former national security
adviser what concerns you most as you're
watching
what concerns me gail is that obviously
this is horrible for the ukrainian
people the humanitarian crisis that
we're witnessing already but what also
concerns me is is wars like this just
don't stay within boundaries within
borders it's going to bleed over i mean
if you think about what putin has just
done in recent years he's enabled the
serial episodes of mass homicide in the
syrian civil war he has used the most
heinous weapons on earth to commit mass
murder against innocence including
killing hundreds of children at a time
and so this shouldn't surprise us in
terms of russia's brutality and we have
to not assume that this this catastrophe
that we're seeing is going to remain
contained uh within ukraine or even
really the black sea region uh or europe
that's even more terrifying than general
because you hear zilinski begging for
help begging for help and the sanctions
clearly aren't working so what can we
what should we do
well we should do everything we can
right now that doesn't risk a direct
confrontation with with the russians and
so i gail you know how is it that we
have not sanctioned the hydrocarbon
sector right i mean 59
of russia's exports are our oil and gas
and of course we don't want to do that
because there are those in europe who
are afraid of disrupting the economy
well i mean there's gonna be a lot more
disrupted uh than energy supplies if we
don't do everything we can at this
moment and of course gail we've got to
rush
all kinds of support that we can to
ukraine i think the next week is it's
going to be really vital i mean this is
when ukrainians could start running out
of basic you know basic supplies you
know pharmaceuticals and food uh and we
also need to support them with more and
more defensive capabilities so they can
sustain their defensive efforts against
the russians
general uh there's a lot that indicates
this is going to get much worse before
it gets better president zielinski has
said a genocide is being carried out uh
senator lindsey graham got some
attention yesterday for saying quote the
only way this ends is if someone inside
russia takes this guy out and he's
talking about putin there what's your
reaction to that idea
well you know i think what we need is we
needed a russia that ceases its
permanent hostility to to europe and and
the united states and the free world
generally and so a change in in the
nature of that government is what we
need now how that happens will be up to
the russian people but i hope that the
russian people are concluding that their
future is pretty bleak under under putin
this is somebody who has really
victimized his own people you mentioned
this already in terms of how he's just
crushed any journalists who had who had
the courage to to really criticize the
government or to expose his criminality
uh and then also you know
he's he's he's affected their living
standards i mean russian wages have
dropped real wages have dropped for the
last eight years the economy has
stagnated you know his coveted response
was terrible he's he's a criminal and
he's incompetent and so i think we
should be doing everything we can to to
get through his information controls and
get real information uh to the russian
people this is where i think you know
journalists are on the front line right
we see courageous journalists today in
ukraine but there are courageous
journalists in russia who risk their
lives every day some of them have been
murdered right so so
i think the information dimension of the
fight is important and it's related uh
to what senator graham said is that the
russian people need to get rid of this
guy
but the russian people aren't getting
the real information that's a problem
you know we've we've been showing
stories where russian soldiers think
they're coming for a special operation
and they're crying to their mothers and
saying i want to go home i had no idea
this was a war the russian people are
being told a totally different story
i'll tell you gail if there's a bright
side of this maybe we'll begin to
cherish the freedoms that we enjoy in
our country right i mean i you know
we've been engaged in yeah i would say
you know self-flagellation for kind of a
long time here and and uh you know we
have freedom of speech you know we have
a say in how we're governed and what
we're looking at is a dictatorship and
and what happens in the dictatorship
where human rights
and your say and how you're governed is
extinguished and so you know i think
that as we look at the bravery the
courage of the ukrainians and we look at
at really the state of affairs in russia
hey i hope that this helps us get
through the traumas we've been through
you know in the last
in the last several years you know and
yeah we'll gain more confidence
general well said it is a stark and very
clear reminder of the freedoms we have
here and how valuable they really are uh
general mcmaster with peerless expertise
on the world stage thank you very much
general